-How does that feel?
-Amazing.
-I mean, people, we're back.
-People!
-The people are here --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uma Thurman is
on "The Tonight Show." Come on.
You look fantastic.
-Oh, my God. Thank you.
This is my first time in front
of a live audience
in a long time.
-It feels good, right?
-It really does.
-You look fantastic.
How are you? How is the family?
-The family is good.
-Good. Knock on wood, yeah.
How about Maya?
-Maya is great.
-Crushing.
She's following in the footsteps
of her mom, she's an actress --
-Both her parents.
-Both her parents as well.
-Actually, I wouldn't say
she's following our footsteps.
She's crushing it.
-She's crushing it
on "Stranger Things."
-Yeah, doing great.
-I remember I was hanging out
with you, and Maya --
-She was this big.
-Yeah, she was a baby,
and you were reading her
"Ferdinand."
-"Ferdinand," I know.
-That was the book you were
reading and I was like --
I didn't know what that was
at the time.
So, and I remember --
-Now you do.
-I have two little girls.
And I read them "Ferdinand."
So, you have a small part
in raising my children.
-I like that. I like that.
-You did a great job.
-"Ferdinand," you know,
the bull that won't fight.
-I love it, it's the greatest.
The greatest book.
She's keep crushing it.
Did you know "Stranger Things"
before she was on it?
-Oh, yeah.
Her brother and I watched the
whole thing. We loved it.
She actually didn't even know
about it when she auditioned.
-She didn't know about it
and you knew about it.
You're like,
"Oh, no. We know --"
-No, because he was like my TV
watching partner.
And we're like, "Okay, this
whole thing's TV revolution
that's going on.
I've got to figure it out."
-Yeah.
-So, my son and I watched it.
-Binge watched everything.
-Yeah.
We would watch altogether.
-And does she let you know
any spoilers or anything or --
-No, no.
-She's good.
-Good kid, yeah.
-She's good, yeah. She's solid.
-Does she ask for advice?
-Only occasionally.
-Yeah.
She knows everything,
like all children.
-Like all children do, yeah.
She's crushing it.
Tell her congratulations.
-I will.
She wants to come on your show.
-She -- oh, my gosh.
Maya, come on the show.
We'll talk about --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll read "Ferdinand."
Not only do you have one
project.
You have two giant projects
that we can talk about.
So, I'm happy that you're here.
I want to talk about "Super
Pumped" the story of Uber.
But I want to know first about
the other show on Apple TV.
This is "Suspicion."
-Yes, "Suspicion."
You said it for suspiciously,
like you weren't quite sure.
-No -- I'm suspicious, yeah.
I don't want to give
anything away. yeah.
-Don't tell anyone.
-What is "Suspicion" about?
-"Suspicion" is about --
it's kind of a who done it,
and kind of eco-terrorism.
Where sort of the good guys and
the bad guys get all mixed up.
I play a cold, strong
business woman
whose son has been kidnapped.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-Did you film this one
during the pandemic?
-I did.
I did both during the pandemic.
But there were two flavors
of the joyful pandemic.
There was
the pre-vaccination flavor,
which "Suspicion"
was shot during.
Which was really required
a lot of courage.
And I think it's very important
to actually try to get back
and be in the workplace.
I admit it was scary.
-Yeah. We need it.
-I, in fact, did burst
into my tears
in my trailer at least once.
You know, when you find out
somebody maybe
isn't feeling well --
-Yeah, it's scary.
-It's real.
-Yeah.
-And then the post-vaccination
working situation,
which is a lot more cool.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, a lot more fun.
-A lot more relaxed, yeah.
Everyone's tested
and everyone's safe.
-People test, people, you know,
like, everybody --
our world is slowly, slowly,
slowly bouncing back.
-Yeah, it is. Yeah, we're coming
back, absolutely, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Super Pumped:
The Battle for Uber."
-Yes.
-I remember --
the cast is amazing, by the way.
Joseph Gordon-Levitt. Shout out.
We love him. He's --
-Shout out!
-Yes, I'm giving him
a shout out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go Joe!
Well, you play
Arianna Huffington.
-I do.
-And I -- you know her, right?
-I have met her a bunch of
times. I don't know her well.
-No.
-But I like her.
-Yeah.
-And I try to play her.
It was the best I could.
-You did a great job.
Is it intimidating to play
someone that's around
and can see you?
-Yeah, no,
it totally is intimidating.
And you do feel quite
responsible.
But I kind of knew
I wouldn't get it right.
I just have to, like,
put my whole heart in it
and practice a lot.
-Yeah.
I want to talk about
nailing the voice.
I want to show a clip
when we come back.
More with Uma Thurman.